il y a deux choses qui peuvent mettre un
terme à la vie sur Terre le
réchauffement climatique et le nucléaire
vous pouvez dire ce que vous voulez le
nucléaire une catastrophe nucléaire
c'est et donc croire que l'une va sauver
l'autre et relève de l'imposture il y a
à un moment donné ce n'est pas de
l'imposture intellectuelle moi je suis
inquiète j'aimerais croire comme des
millions de lobby nucléaires le véhicule
qu'il y a une solution magique qui
permettrait de sortir des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre et qui permettrait
de maintenir notre niveau de vie
actuelle ça n'est simplement pas le cas
toutes les questions qu'on a posé sur la
filière du nucléaire sur la gestion des
déchets sur la compatibilité avec le
réchauffement climatique et les
ressources en eau disponibles le fiasco
du nucléaire et ça a été vu dans la
Commission
le père de Flamanville sait-on
construire un nouvel EPR sait-on
construire vous répondez parce que
quelques secondes on a eu un concentré
d'histoire et de contre première
contre-vérité le nucléaire est en mesure
de mettre fin à l'humanité ça n'a aucun
sens scientifique ça n'a aucun sens
scientifique je vous invite à faire la
distinction entre l'énergie nucléaire
civile et militaire on pourra parler
enrichissement si vous voulez donc c'est
totalement faux deuxième chose vous
l'avez dit mais je pensais même plus que
depuis Dominique Venet on disait ça
aujourd'hui en France vous avez dit je
préfère le carbone au nucléaire vous
venez de le dire vous venez de le dire
si je dois choisir je préfère le carbone
nucléaire dernière chose vous avez parlé
vous avez parlé de l'eau les chiffres
sur le nucléaire et l'eau viennent
d'être mise à jour du refroidissement il
y a une grande partie des réacteurs qui
sont en circuit ouvert et qui donc ne
font que prélever de l'eau et la rendre
très rapidement en souvent en plus d'un
point de vue maritime c'est à dire de la
mère à la mer donc l'impact de
température est faible et
vous avez des centrales en circuit dit
fermé qui consomme une partie de l'eau
12% et non plus 40% et ses chiffres sont
en train d'être Ré